bon messieurs bonsoir
un drôle de nom en parlant du coup c'est
henri de france à part dont
monseigneur monseigneur comme dirait
stéphane bern monseigneur comment
allez-vous très bien très bien alors tu
sais laurent que monseigneur est né en
1933 ce qui vous fait 70 ans et là je
dois dire non franchement à 70 balais
êtes super bien confirmé vent mais
sérieux qua non oui comme entrant
souvent très bien conservés très bien
conservés à 60 ans
c'est pour le faire venir à pour le
faire mais voilà alors depuis la mort de
votre père le comte de paris monseigneur
en 1999 êtes l'aîné d orléans et si la
france avait un roi ce serait vous en
principe oui à mahut ce serait vous
bayal si oui il ya des années il ya
d'autres prétendants 10 en espagne qui
sont plus et n'est que vous mais en même
temps ils sont partis en espagne la fin
des discussions infinies dans lequel on
va pas rentrer ce soir ça sert à rien
enfin disons que pour la plupart des
gens vous êtes le roi de france voilà
respect laurent leur talent respect
total sans déconner toth maladresse
alors on a reçu ce
qu'ils arrivent au lendemain il n'est
pas là
il vient je te jure qu'ils viennent mais
il veut mais tu es qui viennent tout de
suite bien sûr maintenant je sais pas
s'il peut venir tout de suite ça
l'intéresse quand même des générations
avant de se faire coiffer orlando lent
alors on verra dans deux heures
alors
bon seigneur on a reçu ici votre frère
jacques très très remonté contre votre
défunt père il disait que votre père
n'avait de cesse de détruire sa famille
c'est beaucoup quand même surtout quand
ça dérange je ne pense pas je ne pourrai
non vous savez je l'expliquais à un
moment en disant que pour mon père il
avait un contexte le complexe cro magnon
le camp-est cro magnon c'est le vieux
chef qu'il veut pas voir se retire les
jeunes chefs donc on essaye de les
casser et on y avait un autre problème
qu'avait votre frère jacques c'est
qu'ils disaient quand même qu'il ya 200
millions qui ont disparu voilà qu'un 200
millions le patrimoine d orléans à
l'époque où votre père vivait avec
monitrice le pognon a disparu savez je
pense que dans toutes les grandes
familles de de l'âge de mon père cela
veut dire j'ai remarqué que l'argent
disparaît très vite ouais ça quand ils
sont vieux ils soient au public et leur
pognon ou les biens d'une part il ya
peut-être ça d'autre part je crois qu'il
n'était pas fait pour gérer les fortunes
ouais alors ce qui fait que quand on ne
gagne pas d'argent peu mais on en perd
je vais d'abord vint la pallice il en a
tous fait non c'est pas ça attendez le
werder monseigneur peut lui balancer sur
la gueule le verre d'eau si vous voulez
un oui et l'étiquette normes il a déjà
but dans la vie dedans mais comme c'est
pour lui verser sur la gueule en même
temps et alors on jette pas un un verre
à la gueule de quelqu'un dans la cave la
personne a lancé les files non mais
attendez les 200 millions quand même
dans votre père va sans doute dépenser
une partie m'enfin c'est beaucoup de 100
millions ça fait quand même 20 milliards
de centimes monseigneur non en oui vous
savez je ne compte pas ouais je pense
que là qu'on comptait 1 non mais ça vous
embête pas sérieux c'est ce pognon il
est parti on sait pas où il est et vous
vous avez tapé encore de beaux restes ah
bon dans tous les cas vous c'est vrai
que vous n'avez pas été solidaires de
l'action de vos frères et soeurs contre
votre père d'une certaine façon enfants
tous les cas pour récupérer l'héritage
vous n'allez pas
vous a laissé tomber ou non on peut
toujours en récupérer d'autres à
d'autres endroits
c'est un petit peu le cas de votre soeur
s'est connaît votre soeur aussi
tu te souviens de la soeur très sympa
diane dufresne berriane très sympa alors
elle nous a raconté celle est marrante
elle a raconté ses congés payés en
espagne oui elle à pécho tout n'est là
elle a un peu non l appel à pechos la
paix chez aussi elle a péché monseigneur
est-ce que pêcheries cpsia qu'elle n'est
pas allé souper chaud ses péchés
demandera l'abbé de la morandais
ailleurs demandé à michel roth
hollande ou et dans le carré vip ils
auront si tu veux si tu veux voir dans
l'eau il est là comme le montre d'abord
il m'a cassé déjà les oreilles genzyme
vois tellement strydonk que je suppose
que c'est encore un producteur marchand
ce qu'a dit le conseiller d me casser
mon oreille d'or
hollandais qui nous rejoint tout à
l'heure c'est un mec adorable orlando
est vraiment un type formidable bien non
votre soeur nous a raconté un petit peu
ces escapades amoureuses en espagne de
temps en temps elle quitté le duc de
wurtemberg pour ce qu'elle appelait ses
congés payés et elle partait comme ça
quelques mois et puis quand elle
revenait leduc que lui pardonner sympa
j'avais quand on aime quelqu'un on peut
lui pardonner tous dans tous les cas ils
sont sous les royaux 1
sur les royaux
le prince charles lui alors c'est
terrible quand il se tâte pour dubaï il
s'en va les deux sens nous voilà non à
s'affaisser courant ça non sérieusement
chez les rois c'est vous dire mais ceux
qui vont gouverner un jour ce qu'ils
vont avoir des responsabilités
[Musique]
peut-être que ils ont la pression comme
voudraient est alors à ce moment-là
qu'ils attrapent tout ce qui vaut à peu
près
alors votre cousin le futur roi
d'espagne il a attrapé
quoi créer on attrape la craie sans se
plaindre je suis à couper la clim
12 euros le pot non mais c'est vrai
felipe votre j'y voyais très fragile
très froid monseigneur
n'ont atteint damas
notre ami je peux lire le range bien sûr
notre ami henri éléments raconte ses
souvenirs révèle quelques indiscrétions
dans un livre qui s'appelle l'histoire
en héritage qu'il m'a dédicacé américain
qu'est ce qui t'a mis il m'a mis à toi
ma couille pour toujours
le sort des millions c'est à dire que de
combat depuis la dernière émission on ne
montre pas du doigt
bien donc ça s'appelle l'histoire en
héritage ces publié chez tallandier vous
racontez donc tout l'autoritarisme de
votre père alors le pire sans
1984 quand vous épousez votre votre
deuxième femme michaela vous sortez de
la mairie de bordeaux ou chaban-delmas
vient de vous marier et là vous voyez
des micros des appareils photo des
caméras vous vous pensez que c'est pour
votre mariage évidemment pas du tout
votre père vient de vous déshérités il a
fait quelque chose qui n'était qui ne
s'est jamais fait ouais que certains
rois ont essayé de faire avec leur fils
les filles se sont rebellés merci ce que
j'ai fait ouais dans tous les cas il a
dit vous n'êtes plus le le var le roi de
france le futur roi de france de madoff
en france voilà et ça passait
directement à votre fils mais on parle
de ça en angleterre en ce moment dit que
william d'angleterre pourrait régner à
la mort de la reine elizabeth à la place
de son père se dit loin là bas sont pas
les mêmes tendresse en france nous
sommes très stricts là dessus on peut
pas sauter ce qu'ils veulent ils l'ont
prouvé
alors on apprend dans votre livre
monseigneur je vais testions hausse dès
qu un alors vous raconter qu'à l'époque
où vous travaillez pour pour le sdeg
donc en 61 vous éviter qu'un avion soit
battu au nord du maghreb et cet avion
c'est un avion auquel il ya leonid
brejnev quand même donc c'est à oui en
effet ouais vous a sauvé la vie de
britney est d'une certaine façon
oui j'ai une certaine façon et nice
était à deux doigts alors vous raconter
aussi que pendant que vous êtes à la
science politique et un jeune énarque
qui est chargé par votre père de vous
donner des conseils jacques chirac avec
chirac
on était dans le bureau il me faisait
répéter
sur tous les problèmes qui
qui était difficile pour moi c'est
l'économie ouais l'économique je connais
très bien l'agriculture je connais
l'apiculteur là l'apiculteur oh oui les
abeilles se ressasser royal
a fait la boulette
l'apiculture de check-in conneries est
ce que vous trouvez qu'il est bon pour
la france comme présent la république
écoutez demandé à tous les français qui
l'ont élu ouais
mais vous là on va pas avoir le temps
matériel de compliquer ce que vous
pouvez pas répondre au nom de tous les
français puisque entrepris en arrêt
symbole voilà vous avez voté pour chirac
dernière présidentielle
je vote dans un isoloir
ouais mais pour qui
toute façon je vais vous dire ne pas
croire qu'un orléans et voter pour le
fun donc après l'armée où vous faites
l'armée dans légion étrangère gamme
comme votre père d'ailleurs qui s'était
engagé en rang 40 hélas ses scoops h et
non seigneur monseigneur entre crédit
lyonnais tu sais les clippers secret lie
mitchell non plus arlette laguiller
ballon
avec nagui en plein 68 vous devenez le
collègue d'arlette laguiller a été
comment et emiliano stage l'année
écoutez c'est elle qui était avec la
devant les portes
interdisant aux gens de rentrer dans le
crédit lyonnais avait elle faisait
piquet de grève quoi piquer les
électeurs les moi j'étais avec les
pigeons
certains dirigeants du crédit lyonnais à
ces prêts d'eux dans mon bureau et elle
laissait passer monsieur floegel et tous
ces gens là et puis moi j'essayais de
passer même d'y goûter vous non je fais
pas dit jusque là haye donc vous vous ne
rentrerez pas avec eux j'ai visité les
musées alors il ya là le pen ça s'est
passé comment votre rencontre avec
l'opel gtc des amis avocats j'ai des
amis avocats oui alors eh bien alors
dans quand je rencontre ce genre de
personnage là
il ya une tactique entre mon épouse et
moi
elle pose des questions moi j'écoute et
je regarde j'observe
est la fin
à la fin il me dit
eh bien
je serai votre général je serai votre
général qui a quitté brest est à votre
service pour reconquérir le trône alors
je vais beaucoup franco je lui dis je
vous mets mes généraux je me lâche 3 y
aille à dakar à fin de non-recevoir à le
pen bien bossé
bien à vous pouvez aussi les américains
dans votre bouquin monseigneur vous
parlez d'intégrisme américaine c'est à
dire que finalement vous les trouvez
assez assez irritant un très irritants
et vous dites et là je suis désolé une
petite erreur dans votre livre vous
dites leur politique économique et
étrangère se résume à trois mots nous
d'abord nous ensuite parce que c'est
vraiment de se dire mais ça fait quatre
mois que le nous et clown et à tous
d'accord avec ça je m'en tape un prix
machine même pas
bien quand vous parlez de raffarin vous
dit tu entre la france d'en haut et la
france d'en bas il ya une ligne maginot
faisait milieu j'ai pas dis ligne
maginot mais presque
savez j'ai écrit une fois que j'aimais
pas le mot beurre
parce que il n'ya pas des français d'une
couleur dorée c'est d'une autre couleur
pour moi il ya que des français on va
pas les mettre dans des cases
comme on va pas les mettre en route va
pas les mettre en bas vous êtes d'accord
d'accord du ceneri
il vous aime bien
alors vous avez un programme juste bon
seigneur à un programme vous travaillez
avec des conseillers avec des
spécialistes et vous dites airlines je
comprends pas très bien quand vous
paraître votre programme dans votre
bouquin vous dites je fais mon marché à
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
qu'est ce que vous achetez à l'extrême
droite à chacun alors je prends des
bonnes idées ils ont des idées mais il
joue pas devant une réponse qu'est ce
qui a alors coupé la clim mais elle est
coupée dans son élan on regarde ses
forces et neuf sur le plateau voulait
pas la couper dakhli
va voter démocratiquement oui oui laissé
tomber ses 43 trop froid lève la main
on laisse la crise allez ce n'est que ma
voix c'est démocratique c'est bien ce
suffrage universel
bien
alors s'il y avait un roi enfonce
monseigneur serait roi de france on l'a
dit donc on va vous faire une interview
rois de france
[Musique]
bien
si vous étiez roi de france qui serait
votre reine mon épouse à qui serait
votre favorite
mon épouse votre épouse est sérieusement
elle ferait les deux rôles elle frère
est les favoris louis ah ouais d'accord
qui serait votre richelieu bien je vais
vous dire est à le premier ministre se
met les français qui vont le choisir
fait oui puisque c'est une royauté
constitutionnel est d'accord il y aura
des élections et il y aura donc à la
liste mais c'est réglé
donc ces aspects en angleterre c'est de
l'air en espagne c'est le chef du parti
qui gagne les élections ce serait votre
premier ministre alors vous habiteriez
versailles ou le château de la star ac'
monseigneur non non ni l'un ni l'autre
n'avaient pas le château de la star ac
je vais vous dire si
imaginons
pourquoi faire des dépenses inutiles
versailles c'est tout le blé non non
l'elysée est meublé l'elysée avec jerry
à l'elysée voyage il ya toute la
machinerie ouais le bouton pour la bombe
atomique est ce que vous remplaciez la
marseillaise si vous étiez roi de france
monseigneur
non
non parce que la musique est très bel
échange les paroles quand même je
demanderai de frein référendum là dessus
c'est vachement bretons aux français lui
génial mais attendez c'est énorme ça
vous allez faire que demander aux
français oui je vais les faire
travailler
c'est ça les rois en même temps c'est la
démocratie a dit moi avons signé en
feriez quoi des grimaldi là si vous
étiez rois de france
malki rage sur leur rocher ouais vous
soyez pour un rapprochement avec leroy
merlin
là j'ai une question
monseigneur vous feriez quoi si vous
étiez roi de france pour éviter la
révolution eh bien je ferai
nous demanderons aux français de voter
non de faire des cahiers de doléances à
pied et après tout coupe la tête il fait
des choses non est-ce que vous coupent
laurier la clim si vous étiez là
ouest-france d'histoire
c'est édité chez tallandier la baisse et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu